we got today before the conference
starts to actually see Vienna because
for the next five days we're going to be
well doing science all day hopefully so
we're hoping to hit the big sites and I
guess old to you long
okay so never done this before this is
gonna be quite interesting can i vlog on
the street so we just went inside since
students Cathedral which is that and
I've got some footage of it here it's
amazing actually because there was a
full mats going and we both thought it
was a recording no it was a full
orchestra with with full player you know
with full of course nothing so we're now
going to try and find spanish riding
school and tom is navigating by the Sun
and ages old Memphis which hopefully
will do a solo this time and right okay
we will see they're all
well I think it's all the really
important buildings Indiana mr. probably
unfortunately because they're all the
important buildings in Kenya and if you
want to sneeze inside you okay so we've
got some footage of from the Lipizzaner
from the Spanish school being led out
but everything else been it's paid for
in other news though we are going to a
concert Strauss yes the conference
that's the one in Vienna this is a term
that is not the Danube this is a much
less interesting just canal so the
current plan is we're gonna try and go
to this park we're gonna get the subway
which is confusingly free we haven't
quite worked out how the ticket system
worked it's not like we're too PhD
students or anything but like we read
there now and as Tom is also displaced
though Vienna we don't understand your
traffic system do people just do red
lights is being optional we just got run
over
okay so apparently well it's one of the
Danube there's two it splits in the
middle of Vienna because there's a park
which is either that or that which will
probably that which splits into two but
yeah I see the Danube all it's someone
some parasailing that bridge this is the
Danube we think it's all that stuff I
said about the other river
it's quiet too this one instead why is
everything about you so confusing via
why is everything in German as well okay
so we found the eg you what we're in
right now is the lip is blue but it's
the basement of one of the Falls there's
two buildings that are taking place in
that if you can see behind but it's
really big
I mean only the double thousands of
people come into it like this is one of
the poster halls and there must be
getting on for a thousand poster spots I
mean in this hall alone and there's
several of them so we're kind of here
today we just picked up all of our stuff
which I'll go through you probably
already see me go through I guess or
you're about to now
so they gave us at the conference which
every person who's registered gets you
get one of these so a name badge and
with that name badge on the back there's
like a transport ticket so you can get
unlimited bus tram and subway travel
during the week to in from the
conference which is good and also a
memory stick on the lanyard which has
all the abstracts in the program the
main stuff that they gave us if I pick
it up so they're doing this think of the
face of the earth which is the theme for
the conference and there's this one hand
I'm getting used to vlogging like this
so they have a theme herb a and there's
a keynote lecture and is also a
demonstration this thick thing really
sick thing actually which is the program
so the EGU covers basically every kind
of Geoscience imaginable they break it
down into like what car scientists we've
got atmospheric science climate energy
magnetism energy resources and rocks so
there's thousands and thousands of
people who've got poster sessions and
then also there's talks and I'm in
addition to that there's like there's
debates the symposia there's workshops
I'm hopefully gonna go to at least one
workshop which is about scientists
making films which is all residents mean
in addition to that we also got this
massive book mom wasn't really long
enough to capture all which is about the
life of Edward Edward Suez who was a
really important earth scientist
generally in german-speaking countries
he basically invented modern geology and
he died a hundred years ago in 1914 so
they published this book which has got
essays in introductory essays on like
the dynamics of quiet earth water
problems and all that kind of stuff and
quotes from him to celebrate his life
which is really really cool and that's
why they've been in the face of the
earth as their theme because the face of
the earth was a coin they a phrase that
he coined to talk about the way the
earth presents itself
1124 blue posters there we go and I mean
how many colors blue red green yellow
right yeah yeah sorry Thomas is looking
through the the program guy that we've
got and I'm behind you you can see there
are various people setting up but you
know people's prove something finished
yet it's crazy
look at hang on let's look at this look
at the thickness of that it's ridiculous
sorry you weren't even in shock then
okay Tom's gonna become the unwitting
star of my blog right so me and Tom
discovered that the best laters weren't
working in the building
but if taught you do you want to go
downstairs Tom what's this
wow that motion detectors of what
escalators it's the same see someone's
kind of man so you've had a merry jaunt
in this through various things the guy
that we got the noodle from didn't give
us any chopsticks or well Forks or
anything so I'm actually having to use
depends what with me to eat
which work supposingly well actually if
I welcome to this time your face so
we're doing now as we're walking down
this this massive park which is 13 miles
long 13 miles long and she's gonna try
and cross over to a tram station where
they're gonna try and take in the art
district and then hopefully go to this
concert so we'll see you at what those
hopefully
well I think it's his wife Maria Teresa
who we don't know you don't know what if
the dinner why I think she I think she
was the person who single-handedly
wrestled of Vienna to the ground with
her bare hands or something like that
I'm not ever she tuned
we went to this concert so it was in can
you remember the name of the palace and
it was a mixture of remote start on the
Strauss who saw the two famous composers
associated with Vienna and it was done
by people in period costumes so read
friendly dresses for the ladies and
white tie for guys today was basically
the one chance we had to do cultural
stuff so we thought we'd make the most
of it and we got to hear the Blue Danube
in Vienna which is kind of like as good
as music stuff gets so these are the
cases of Matt behind me where people
have submitted rocks
it's nice people are sometimes